In this lesson, you'll use Salesforce to quickly visualize your data using
charts, reports and dashboards. Sam and Andy are going to help you with that.
>> So, it seems like if you're a music festival manager, there
are a ton of opportunities for visually conveying information to other people.
>> Totally. I mean, with all of the
different things that you're tracking, maybe you want to track
things that are over time, or maybe you
want to track just the distribution of a specific thing.
>> Like VIP
tickets versus general admission, or money over time, or something like that.
>> Exactly, and just like whenever
you're charting anything, there are different types
of charts that you might want to use in order to display that information.
>> Yeah.
>> Or, maybe we just want to create reports on it.